greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 24th of October get your
[ __ ] together
the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you and welcoming its orig
let me tell you something bout the rich
you know you know much pointless stuff
we carry in our wallets receipts hotel
room keys spent gift cards
the leather bifold zat menus resemble
suitcases more than wallets the ridge
helps you carry less but always what you
need okay it's sleeker than a wallet
it's two metal plates bound together by
durable elastic elastic bands the ridge
looks nothing nothing like a traditional
wallet you get them titanium carbon
fiber and aluminum options ensures
there's no there's an option for
everybody what do you use it a leather
wallet what do you like the ridge is
minimal a front pocket wallet that's
designed to let you ditch your bulky
wallet the ridge wallet is slim RFID
blocking and lifetime guaranteed listen
it's the last wallet you'll ever buy
right now alright
it comes in titanium carbon fiber and
aluminum and a poly carbonate and over a
dozen different styles and colors I'm
really impressive I'm really impressed
but I brought one for Leigh tonight and
I'm really impressed with it what I'm
gonna do is this I'm gonna give you 10%
off with free worldwide listen to me
worldwide shipping by going to Ridge
wallet dot-com you gotta see this to
believe it
Ridge wallet dot-com slash Church again
that's Ridge wallet coms last Church now
again I don't know how many times I have
to tell you people I don't know how many
times I got to tell you people that from
now till December 31st
it's a player's paradise it's time to
make some money you want to make some
money
my bookie is the way to go you're
looking at me going joy what are you
talking about my book my bookie has been
around forever they got great online
reviews and let me tell you something
they pay when you win and that's the
most important thing my bookie is won
one of the best bets you'll be happy
with all year I recommend these guys
because I trust them like I said they've
been in business
for years and then but nothing but good
uncle Joey and their mobile site is
easy-peasy to use stop being on the
sidelines it's time for you to get in
the game what I'm gonna do is this what
login to my bookie right now and I'm
gonna double your money
you're like Joey what are you talking
about no banking that lunch I'm gonna
double your money you put a hundred and
you get two hundred use promo code
Church CH you are CH and you'll get your
first deposit matched a hundred percent
that's promo code Church CH you are CH
you play you win you get paid check that
[ __ ] melee it's like a jungle
sometimes it makes me wonder how I keep
from going under cuz I got you
[ __ ] welcome to the church
what's happening now with water welcome
Jeff Tomczyk director producer good
all-around [ __ ] dude ari should be on
his way but [ __ ] him he's got a Jewish
guy who [ __ ] running with a rickshaw
and he won't be here for two hours well
show Brian we have been right Scalia
what's going on Jeff Thompson man you
know I'm just have I'm out here doing my
Bhandari pony show around town trying to
get the next thing set up you know this
man
you know it's like well I told you a
right now Bradley Cooper was on the
phone with an agent so they argued about
his next move yeah there's always
something people always think that oh
he's got it made you always argue it
you're always somebody every week some
somebody somewhere tries to pull a
[ __ ] Louie Lamora and you gotta put
him in check and then you feel bad and
it's a [ __ ] harvest show people so
when you see [ __ ] these people and
shows trust me
they got [ __ ] what do they call those
uptown problems yeah uptown proverbs
real problems yeah first of all problems
yeah first world first no no this first
world problems my probably and then
there's people that have up style
problems you know you're not gonna
believe this but my condo under the
penthouse flooded if I ever get to that
place man just me I am no it's a
different [ __ ] level and stuff like
that how long have you been directing
for well I you know I started well I
don't know getting paid to do it or just
directing in general well I think like
the first time I had a camera
was my grandfather as he gave me when I
was like nine years old and I forced my
sister to do like weird remakes of Star
Trek episodes in my basement when I was
nine and it's sort of crazy to me that
I'm even doing this for a living now but
that was my hobby even as a kid and then
directing for like in a job yeah 10 10
11 years I went well I grew up in I was
born in Chicago but I grew up mostly in
Iowa my parents moved there when I was a
kid when we were in Iowa there's you
know being a director is like you know
it's the farthest thing from reality my
father was like man maybe engineering
yeah that's a that's a reasonable career
just creative as you can get yeah that's
exactly right
like there's things like cameras you
know there's there's machines anyway but
I I went to the University of Iowa and I
studied film but I also studied computer
science because that seemed like the
sensible thing to do and I you know I
even thought that I would go into
graphics you know do CG [ __ ] for movies
maybe that would be possible you know
but I was making stuff and doing plays
even then and in high school before that
and then I came out to LA to go to fi
you know which is this you know great
graduate program for film and I dropped
out on the second day when I realized
that it was that I was gonna go $120,000
into debt and everyone else at school
was showing up in a 7 Series BMW at 25
and I was like oh this is I'm from a
different world I can't afford this so I
I sort of flirted with doing a graduate
program but then but then left and went
back back to work and started doing
commercial shortly after that so serious
and I was like oh then I was like 14
years ago but what was your first job
like you were they be obviously I work
well I did everyday you know again I
like even after I moved to New York City
after college in 99 and did everything I
could possible I worked as a grip I
worked as a an electric I worked an
editor I shot film as a DP you know
because it never never felt real to me
to say I'm a director like I feel like I
need to earn it and learn whatever other
person on the
did like have respect for the whole
picture and it took acting classes and
stuff like that before I felt like I was
comfortable like this is what I'm gonna
do my first job was right after that I
actually directed some commercials for
speed stick deodorant in 2004 no that
was the first real paid gig yeah
and there would have been real TV
commercials they were like online
commercials which is a brand new thing
then this is like before real YouTube
happened and all that so it was sort of
a half job but you remember with the big
splurge was gonna be the internet
commercial yeah yeah we let me tell you
something I wanted from going out for
film auditions and TV auditions to just
going out for [ __ ] you lis you name
it they were again we're talking about
right I'll say it before the show yeah
Lee every day I was going out for a
Heineken web series yep
Cadillac web series everything was gonna
be web series so they didn't pay very
well oh you're [ __ ] wrong really
so what happened was I kept going out
for them yeah this is the big was it
2004 2000 in a couple days yeah yeah
yeah they were pushing for a new medium
that come along yeah a new medium will
come along the paid commercials from our
line yep and they called it something
that online the media is something so
you were going for these commercials and
it didn't say national or international
or Internet no it did say Internet yeah
they called it new media new media snow
but that it yeah
and it was like 800 scale and they
couldn't work you over for hours it was
something [ __ ] crazy Lee like
something that you're like what yeah and
if you worked over five hours they had
to pay you double and and it was like it
was new whatever and I have gone to call
back so I started getting called back I
started getting called back so I started
getting caught by it's not it all these
people around me of booking these
[ __ ] you know booked a couple of them
red is easy if I'm not wrong
yeah a couple of [ __ ] web series with
a page a man and I finally I booked this
movie called pizza and bullets Talia
Shire oh really
big [ __ ] from The Sopranos ha ha hey
just a bunch like these be guys was a
great script yeah but it was a hundred
hours a day
mm-hmm okay what it was a hundred
dollars a day that's crazy this is the
beginning of it this is $100 a day movie
yeah
really came because when I got here was
all scale yep which again I'm not
complaining I'm just informing you how
it happened yeah everything was 650 9+10
yeah or whatever it is right and then a
buddy of mine that was in the movie
se7en he got a movie and he put me in
and it was for 59 a day and then when I
did the Rodney Dangerfield movie was for
59 a day mmm then I did some other film
it was 250 a day I just kept going to
called low-budget yep and then ultra-low
budget sag is a hundred houses damn so I
got the offer to do this pizza and
bullets but they were still in the
process of writing the script
mmm-hmm so in that process bad I get an
audition for Mountain Dew for a web
series playing a bear I hope that
there's somewhere I want to see that for
sure it's 800 for four hours work yeah
and it was just crazy
cuz I've heard I was on the post side
and I've heard I had friends who would
do online stuff and they would always
complain that they will work on huge
things but would get almost nothing no
we were getting this is a very beginning
when they've started getting popular as
I remember I went all the way to the end
with this with the Cadillac people and
there was a James Bond remake type deal
and it was 16 episode yeah I remember
the reenactment yeah yeah it was crazy
people going crazy but nobody was
showing him yeah he couldn't find him
you couldn't find [ __ ] one of them
everybody wish you were going to
auditions them
so now in the process of pizza bullets
there like every Monday they work all go
listen we don't know what the schedule
is we're gonna call you next week
yeah call you next week so this went on
for two weeks and I got a callback for
the Mountain Dew and boom I get the
[ __ ] call back again it was a
nightmare I know it was a nightmare had
to go to our first and then I had to go
to [ __ ] Beverly Hills then the final
callback was downtown and boom I booked
this and I'm like [ __ ] yeah ten episodes
guaranteed 800 that's 7,200 that's
without overtime they had a bunch of
line so a bunch of little ones lunch $25
cash every day
this whole [ __ ] scared we beat some
bullet calls and then and the first day
of me shooting whatever Mountain Dew mmm
it's my calls at 2:00 in the afternoon
Ogawa and pizza and bullets wanted me at
7:00 in the morning and I celebrated
getting the Scooby Doo thing the
Mountain Dew thing by getting way to G's
occult that's how I celebrated ah and
I'm up all night Jeff Thompson [ __ ]
jerking off [ __ ] doing blow
celebrating 70 200 and the next morning
I'm like if Pete's and bullets thanks
brother show up cuz they had me on the
street right right and also how the
[ __ ] blue they call the day that
Mountain Dew calls yeah oh my god oh the
guys I'm starting to get the flu Wow
koalas in the morning is he how you feel
I don't want to get the set in fact that
now he's just trying to push it off I
woulda shot the movie right I gotta get
this seventy to one thousand Oh yep I
can't risk one hundred dollar bill to
play a [ __ ] gangster in a movie that
might not go yeah that morning that's
what I wake up to his den pounding my
wife was all around wow they're pounding
of the door and I went out and pushed a
kid they call the cops
I've got press charges but the producer
said you'd never work again the casting
people were furious they were furious
was it for like a studio
production company anything now the guy
but this is this is this is how the
Internet's taken over the studio
business that's a good sin a nutshell it
was like and guess what happened guys I
got a call at one o'clock
Mountain Dew scrap the project but we
were still getting a check of the map oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
then the best call you ever got your own
it was a you know you think about it
yeah it was a three week process yeah
there wasn't a comedian that didn't say
how wonderful Mountain Dew today I think
I'm gonna book everybody had gone in
them no matter what size shape color
like they wasted people's time yeah like
that dude what's that commercial that
[ __ ] the guy that gets beat up on the
Allstate commercial oh yeah camera or
the guys name I know twenty dudes that
was it of course and they made him jump
off buildings
deep voice guy from 30 rock no state
commercial that's polite the white dude
always damaged so he's gonna I'm at a
wedding party yeah
and I'm about this eat the ring and he
eats the ring and he gets hit by a car
you know that they were you know I had
like three buddies who won't have factor
that were regular schmoes like me I'm
sure and they had them jumping off
buildings and [ __ ] do what that was
for the audition process just some
jackass like jumping and they knew all
along they were gonna give it to this
[ __ ] guy that's ridiculous
I'm not surprised they think it breaks
but it breaks my [ __ ] heart I was
telling somebody that about three years
ago I got a call right from New York to
one to something with a bunch of zeros I
I take the message and it's a casting
director that wants me for a specific
role and she goes do you mind if I send
you the size they're a little offensive
like a wall if you just thought of me
for the specific role you know why would
they be offensive he said alright cut
this [ __ ] and it was just about a [ __ ]
yeah there was a guy describing a [ __ ]
that's a Cadillac you got a sticky dick
and [ __ ] good from time to time
that's a mercedes-benz of [ __ ]
something you'd say so I want a wittle
or okay and I put on tape it wanted to
take
to 72 hours I sent it they called me
back they said listen your number one
choice mm-hmm you just but understand
you know we're not gonna pay for the
flight and we're not gonna pay for the
hotel it's a New York hire I had a place
to stay yeah I guess Lyon I got a bunch
of miles I could use I always save miles
case somebody dies is um yeah you got a
plane ticket no drama
dark I said you got it
it shoots May 8th it's a cape reward is
it for a movie or a show move yeah it's
the it's the [ __ ] Pacino movie when
he played the [ __ ] thief or but De
Niro and Michelle Pfeiffer when he
played the stockmarket fraud guy with
movies that son HBO guys De Niro and
Michelle Pfeiffer and who robbed what
would [ __ ] what he's looking at them
what it was the [ __ ] guy that robbed
their big right now Bernie Bernie Madoff
right right right yep they kept call me
back the family or the Wizard of Lies
maybe wizard was yeah it was allies chap
they called me six times to say we just
want to remind you that when you get
this move we're not gonna pay for a
plane ticket they had the agent call me
the casting director call me the
producer that's not a small project why
can they fly you out there for that so
guess what I never hear from loop again
oh my dad and also the movie comes out
and then I'm Hank Azaria so you called
me 20 times but then you know it
you knew I know you [ __ ] how to fly
Hank Azaria that's thing of course they
did unless you knows I am like so all
this drama you gave me about a [ __ ]
three hunting on JetBlue you gave it to
Hank Azaria anyway so it's just it's
such a it's such a [ __ ] weird thing
when they way they have money they have
so much money to spend that it's
ridiculous
yeah everything gets a nickel to dive at
some point it's crazy what I don't get
it when was that that was that that was
recently what's that that that movie The
Wizard a lot yeah two years ago yeah
that seems when I shot grudge match
there was no plane ticket no
really I had to put that I would lived
in Houston
there's gonna this guy [ __ ] scares me
because I had now directing I don't hear
this now they gave me a hotel now and I
had miles on Delta mm-hmm and what I did
was because they could only shoot me two
days one week and one day like four days
later I just sent up little shows in New
Orleans smart and I did some stand-up
and then I made the best of it you know
and I made a little money bomb in the
box office
so the residuals are dismal I get one
three times a year and I got to work
with De Niro and the experience yeah but
all right 20 years ago I wish I would
get here cuz they'll tell you when you
walked into 200 North LaBrea I've never
the PETCO that was the big audition in
place I got and it would tell you
exactly when you signed then what the
situation was gonna be so it would say
let's say you won then tomorrow October
23rd
there we go jell-o pudding shoot Denver
Colorado 11 1 to 11 6 ok when you booked
that commercial they flew you to Denver
on October 31st they took you to dinner
and they broke down the situation to you
and they'd say Lee guess what you're not
shoot until the 4th and you're like so
why my hand only wall because we're
gonna put you an old towel room and
we're gonna give you under $75 a day per
diem and you don't know ok just in case
some changes there why do they always
want you that yeah yeah yeah that's what
they were doing you would stay the 6
days and you even had the best time of
your life they would they would tell you
to come to the set and I missed out on
this whole this whole era
yeah where there was so much now there's
just so much [ __ ] out there now you
booked a commercial it says 111 1 to 11
7 and you'll get flown in on 11 4 you
will shoot on 11 5 there will not be a
stitch over time yep you'll be on that
plane the next time you shoot for teen
commercials on 11 5 yeah yeah yeah it's
a different yeah
is no waste yeah it's crazy there's just
because there's so much stuff out there
that like they they don't have the money
for any one thing anymore I think you
know it's like their Instagram ads
online ads of TV ads there's a million
people making all this [ __ ] it's hard to
for anything to matter if I had a
company I'd be doing it into the net
yeah complete ooh do right now which I
love to do with a guy like you is
already commercials for the internet now
that'd be great pick the level up yeah
or just a little bit yeah and do r-rated
Commerce's we find out what do you tube
it's a grant whatever is and just kick
the level up a little bit yeah
just a little bit no nudity no nothing
stupid just a little bit just something
to push the envelope to sell your
product for it to be a little different
no naked ass what does that count is
there whatever we got so example down
table no and I if [ __ ] yeah what's the
Mayans is some [ __ ] Sun Network now I
think they then they show someone's ass
on network television already
isn't that happened years ago come on
I'll sit chairman Lee you know this but
I mean I don't know if you know but how
much are they are they still spending a
lot more on TV and than they're spending
online or is it starting to get more
even I mean they're spending so much the
weird thing is like when I made tag when
I mean the movie is they didn't spend a
dime on print advertising it all went
online and it was and that's only
recently happened but it makes sense but
they're not doing any ads in magazines
and papers all that's gone not much
radio anymore it's really all podcasts
it's a lot of Instagram Facebook and
still some TV but it seems like it's
more more shifting towards Instagram I
mean I that's where I see most [ __ ] okay
so you in New York before we get to tape
you in New York yeah you direct speed
stick yeah and then what's next well you
like you're saying it was like a weird
time right like suddenly and I'd moved
out there and got it at college and when
the like the first like Internet 1.0
started and then failed pretty quickly
and like after September 11th and I was
doing there was almost a youtube thing
going on there
but then it completely went away and
sort of came back in oh four oh five and
for everyone I knew like UCB New York
like Crowell and at poly and Mulaney and
Aziz and pupil all those guys are there
were improvisers they were all getting
money make these web series and you know
it was like you know it was like 10
grand for five episodes or 15 grand for
tonight I mean we're all broke as [ __ ]
so that was like the greatest thing in
the world to go make a comedy web series
for 15 grand you know then you could
stretch it out you know shoot for six
seven days because no one expected to
get paid so I was doing that as much as
I could and I made a short on my own and
then got into AFI came out here
dropped out like he said good did ads
for a while and it took years I worked
at MTV and marketing and then in promos
so I've made more sort of branded
advertising you know through the like it
was 700 eight it's actually I started
smoking I was making an anti-smoking
campaign for the truth and yeah and the
only place you could go to have like
private conversations was the smoking
area because that was it was hidden from
the client so like the library all the
crew and the producer would go there and
smoke so and we're shooting overnights
in Queens
it's [ __ ] miserable in like a grocery
store and and one night I'm just like
but it give me one of those Parliament's
oh I'm so [ __ ] tired there's like
4:00 in the morning or something like
that in Queens and the next night it was
like I'll take give me another one of
those have wake me up a little bit and
then I bought a pack it all happened on
day the truth coffee yeah that's
ridiculous that's crazy I you pick up
smoking I love it yeah I couldn't get in
your car if I smoke I moved to Iowa you
know it was before I moved that way I
watched Stanhope one night how he would
be a certain mood and once he started
smoking he would be a certain mood and
one that I had and then I saw Josh wolf
would always blast back the cigarettes
on the way out and throw him away yeah
give him to somebody smoke eight
cigarettes I did yeah I was like that's
not a bad idea one night after all those
years
smoked when I was about six yeah in my
bathroom I got like a now cigarette I
live in them was my [ __ ] god dizzy I
mean I was like this [ __ ] oh yeah when I
was like 13 you know I was I was always
a good kid but my friends decide we'd
steal packed cigarettes went out on this
like out in this park or this golf
course and I smoke three cigarettes and
just puked all over myself and for the
rest of time I was an anti smoker until
you know twenty years later in this
grocery store in Queens at four in the
morning I started pickup parliament's to
stay awake it's miserable I was like the
anti smuggler was putting putting like
firecracker powder my dad cigarettes
that it's so that explodes yeah I was an
[ __ ] me too I was I was anti yeah I
[ __ ] couldn't take it
I could not take you to the room anymore
I'd grown up in bars yeah where you go
home and you wake up a lot morning and
even if you're not smoking now you
remember that yeah I got to know you
close this is worse and they would smell
[ __ ] horrific and if there's anything
I hate odors I hate smells I hate smelly
Nicks
I just hate smelly things look at these
look at these noses we got Joey is a
mouse hit me ah [ __ ]
I hate hippies that don't bathe [ __ ]
again the same way I love candles around
my we're gonna yeah it'll be a nice I
got me my [ __ ] is a lot of smells like
that between the jujitsu gear and the
face have to read goats I got stashed
and the [ __ ] it smells ha I gotta put
a candle in there okay I got a Febreze
the [ __ ] office between farting
sometimes I fart Nick I'm bagging I was
laying it's worse than when I left
it's like a [ __ ] fog the heat is on
sometimes I put the heat to dry the weed
and then I push the button but I don't
push stop and every 20 minutes the heat
goes on for five minutes I won't go far
it's a [ __ ] sauna in there oh yeah so
now here's the thing I had one when you
went to AFI yep
what did you see the first two days that
made you quit well the thing was like
there is a sort of a preseason and we
watch a bunch of movies over the summer
and read a bunch of books think we got
together all the other guys and girls
that were in the in the program we got
together and with like have barbecues
and talking about movies and [ __ ] and
they're all good people so but I like I
hadn't realized that most of them had a
lot more money than me and could
probably afford to go to the whole 120
thousand I mean I imagine that's true of
every not long as a program how many
it's two years but 60,000 a year because
you're taking out you're not supposed to
have a job while you're doing it so
you're basically taking out your living
expenses as well and loves and there's a
great program I don't want to [ __ ] all
over them or were those people because
it's still a lot of my friends but like
for me
I like I also freaked out a lot and
first day that first day at college I
went to try to take an oral exam to pass
out of some oral communications credit
and I got on my bike and rode 40 miles
home to my parents house and I'm not
highway and I was a little bit a little
bites and problems
yeah yeah so I I had a pride like a
little bit of a commitment problem that
has nothing to do with them but like for
me it was a good choice because I went I
took that risk of leaving before those
loans kicked in and I was in the hole
and I probably still paying him off and
then and then I went trading that
commercial and then there was just one
thing slowly and I was broke for a long
time but this I slowly was able to make
more [ __ ] and more [ __ ] try to figure
out what I was doing you know fell on my
face a few times learned a little bit
from it there was a long process man I
was like you know four - that was 14
years ago even thinking about it doesn't
feel it feels like it went by in a
flatter than high but took a long time
to get to a place where I could make a
movie or even make a few TV shows so
trust to me that did you have any
directors that you admired oh sure he
would look at me though this is what I
want to do well the funny thing is like
I I think I originally got interested
because I my dad you put
on the John Carpenter's this thing
remember that movie us from the 80s from
84 I think great man was even before
that he and there's a previous one from
the 50s that Howard Hawks directors
black and white very wholesome not
terrifying he thought I was putting on
that that 1950s film and he actually put
on the John Carpenter r-rated Kurt
Russell film it's [ __ ] terrifying
it's just people's guts spilling its
[ __ ] goriias [ __ ] still my favorite
movie this day but it gave me nightmares
for three weeks I was just [ __ ]
myself screaming having night terrors
sleeping with my parents as a kid but I
came out I came out of that hell storm
and I was like I want to learn how to do
it to other people and I got way into
like horror movies and really you like I
love horror movies man they're my
favorite thing I came out here to be an
editor and I was always petrified like
what if I get a big break and I have to
edit horror cuz I don't I can't I would
do a terrible job III hate like that's a
you get scared easily yeah I jump the
stuff that supposed to basically jump
McJob I jump you're not gonna see the
new Halloween [ __ ] no powers a John Woo
that it's a really weird John because
it's camera angles mmm music it's music
and the pacing yeah if a director can't
do that with horror like I told these
guys just last week on AMC The Exorcist
is better mmm it's been on every day on
yeah and I've been catching twenty
thirty minutes of it mm-hmm and if I
have to say my all-time favorite
directed movie of all time is the
Exorcist woman yet whoever did the
Exorcist freaking freak any shots also
the DP did two or three shots that were
brilliant beautiful you know we have so
many things that are missing like this
people complain all the time and I
appreciate people complaining especially
people my age a little older maybe a
little young I'm not complaining about
the films the seventies the 60s in the
ATM what's getting made today and I
think it starts you know yes it starts
with the script and it starts with the
[ __ ] from the studio and how they
try to pair people up but it also starts
at the director
when I was doing a lot of hundred
dollars a day films there was a time
three years Jeff after 2007 mm-hmm that
I did ten $100 day fellas really well
and I got the work that I asked mmm you
know like I worked on the Harold Ramos
now I'm gonna analyze that the only
reason I knew the movie was over have
was a dog with fleas when I read this
fact I knew was a dog with fleas but I
didn't care
I'm gonna talk to Harold room yeah yeah
I wanted to pick his mother and I like
things he didn't stripes there was just
couple movies he directed afternoon I
think he wrote stripes hero stripes and
roadster oh yeah I haven't directed and
then you know there was just something
that I wanted to ask him about comedy
something about the way he wrote comedy
and stuff that I really liked it was
subtle mm-hmm it was like a finger in
the air I love not literally I like him
I don't like him literally either the
other well I got to West Palm Beach the
other I got am NOT Thursday mmm I've
scrolled through the channels I didn't
really want to go out I asked this dude
and I called Lee right away I know Lee I
was some Italian food and I'm excited
and the food came and I pulled out the
play advice and I had somebody called
and I was charging the phone when I came
and it was Nightmare on Elm Street
hmm okay I haven't seen that movie since
probably 1984 I haven't seen in the
movies I haven't see them will be some
1984
yeah when I came out that time yeah hums
out of the phone yeah like my [ __ ]
heart stopped I still good movie so hold
up it still holds up you know it was a
couple different things that that it's
not hasn't give me this way over at the
cemetery it's over that stuck [ __ ]
sharpshooting basis with the holder of
his neck
[Laughter]
yeah I mean that that movies so good you
know and the weird thing is that you
know the movie I made if his new one was
the same studio and they called the
house of Freddie built because those
movies made so much money that they
created a whole studio it's just that
franchise that's how good those things
were and everything they're funny - I've
seen wet horror
yeah when it's bad what it's bad it's
like a bad comedy but I used to go see
all the lighter horror show
like what was the one with all the young
girls the young kids what was that the
one that they did scream scream yeah
yeah but I also used to go to in the
early days I would go to all those
original just Walking Dead that's why
they were walking dead yeah cuz I got
into the whole George Romero oh yeah I
was a closet of classics I used to go to
Jersey City to midnight movies aren't
some of those horror supposed to be bad
like white did you limitation if you
watch any scene from a George Romero
movie now if you're my age you're like
I'm a bit embarrassed let's just blame
it on the ass alright because my buddies
would take acid we take acid and go to a
[ __ ] light of the Living Dead that
was one and there were racist as [ __ ] oh
yeah like if you think the little
rascals are racist
you haven't seen anything there was one
where the helicopter was taken off and
it was a black he was just killing black
people that bad I'm not living that
there's one of them that about
forgiveness and look what it was George
Romero let's look for 76 76 to 78 maybe
even 75 he put out a movie one of those
things with him it's a zombie apocalypse
and Donna died dad Betty you wanna watch
those yeah you have to you have to but
there's one of them with the guys like
mama mama and he was a black guy he
[ __ ] chopped his head off
they actually come down what's funny cuz
I think the first one he got he had a
black main character and not a living
dead which was a whole thing right
really yeah that did no one had ever
done it in a horror before and then this
guy comes out of Pittsburgh so well
maybe you just undid it in the next the
next one seventy six what are you doing
those years 76 he did Martin and they
did Donald the dead in 78
that was the Lord that killed me
Martin's a [ __ ] up yeah it's a God
thinks he's a vampire in starts just
running around with the syringe drawing
blood from people he's drinking it Oh
crazy not know he's no just the [ __ ]
psychopath the great [ __ ] movie but
doughnut dead is where we would trip in
hard not that we were doing angel dust
are you in some movies we used to go to
the [ __ ] lunchtime so I'm gonna throw
me that angel dust is coming back around
the people are doing PCP probably for
three bucks usually P that's crazy they
would call it something else they used
to call a THC crystal uh how we got into
it and then there are when they would
call it something else and you would Bob
wherever you would buy weed you know you
were able to buy angel dust so the guy
would go I got tens and I got trays Trey
is a three dollar bag and it was
basically a pin or if you rolled it it
wouldn't burn so you had to put it in
the weed roll it and smoke it
what's a minute twelve hours finish
relying tiny twelve hours nine hours of
constant you don't know where you are
constant what's the skinny guy from
Friday Chris card is that they thing
that made him get in the chicken coop
yes I'm way and we went to see
daughter's dead mmm
and I think the open is seen a
helicopter wins yeah it's trying to save
people will get attacked by dead people
Mike and black guy gets on top of a box
to grab the helicopter and the [ __ ]
chapter just walking head right that's
how it opens up and you're like and then
the Marines come in an issue
black yeah that's all I remember the one
one is you know I think me I'm think
maybe there may be the bzb was what came
a Rachel stay bound your brain what came
out of doors nightriders Creepshow Day
of the Dead yeah that was their third in
that trilogy yeah monkeyshines
Oh monkey shines yeah growing up that
today he only I don't he's lonely
anymore
he quit sci-fi yeah he said he called
into a podcast we were in a band
together in the sixth grade uh-huh and
he wanted to work for sci-fi he was a VP
of development really work for them he
told us the story and he goes but I
started paying attention town my kids
were watching TV mm-hmm but every time I
would tell sci-fi they would tell me to
go [ __ ] myself until one that cashed in
my pension I told him to go [ __ ] hahaha
and he's a horror show freak so he
bought horror movies from all now well
put him on YouTube seven dollars a month
he got the last I heard he had the
subscribers he was made a lot of money
man I did he sold it yeah and then he
started something else he couldn't start
a horror genre har was big when I was
growing up well you know the funny thing
to me is like I thought I wanted to do
it forever and then I got a car yeah and
I thought and there's a weird there's a
weird similarity between horror movies
and comedy to maybe there's like they're
both they're both like such a visceral
things it's so subjective but like if
they function sort of in the same way
you just exchange jokes for scares in
those movies getting fries right yeah
it's that it's that like that laughs and
that scare sort of like activating the
same part of your brain it's like that
this like release so why I think that
best horror movies are sort of I have
big laughs in them too like dude they
are really comedy and campy all these
horror movies yeah that's weird
when you look at jackass it is almost
the same it's like the guy getting
punched then like kicked in the nuts by
a donkey replace that with getting
stabbed by a monster they're both funny
yeah there's difference between horror
and like thriller I can almost do
thriller I just don't like whenever they
have those do ghost or demon movies and
they
tukutz and they appear to nowhere in
light jump and I look and I'm like oh
yeah well I'm getting a conjuring
tobacco such a good movie
we're gonna watch together I just want
to watch you scream oh I would die
I was the I'd a got cradled yesterday
there was Sunday like I said the
exercises have been on all week
yeah and I had the morning off I did a
couple things I ran some errands and I
get home but I my wife cause she doesn't
mean the baby gonna stop at rouse and
won't come home be over maybe you know
what this is gonna be the only chance of
mine yet let me go watch the squadron to
England game mmm and the wingman was up
31 24 with like 9 minutes left to go and
like oh let me see what else is on the
Exorcist huh
and it was from the scene when the
priest walk then yeah well he's coaching
him well yeah priest goes to him he was
a psychiatrist yeah he's like listen I
think I'm gonna listen
Satan is coming you should get to you
psychologically you can't listen to him
he's a liar and he attacks you
psychologically that's how he attacks
you and I'm watching the camera angles
and how the Exorcist scares the [ __ ] out
of you without saying a word we don't
show blood they don't show anything yeah
she petrifies you the heat when he
elevated what she elevated yeah
and they had to shoot that in a freezer
yeah you'll get to see my breath the
breath since that's an added that little
girl should sue the studio today problem
wife oh my god she never recovered from
guys oh now your eyes over from that at
12 she showed up three years later with
Russia 12 she was 12 with dirty Rick
James tell me all about that he was
dating rich ain't no [ __ ] way yeah
The Exorcist girl yeah Linda Blair I'm
gonna blend a Blair that's right she
wanted to do a lot of stuff though right
that's why I know her name [ __ ] it's
pretty much over
nary tale for you last night
was when the mother comes in and she
smacks her than a head spins around yeah
and then she went the mother got Jesus
shocked at the cross yeah she still
having a [ __ ] effect [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
yeah the mother's like what the [ __ ] and
then she takes him by the ears and she
makes a read of [ __ ]
yeah actually here but boy were you
doing that she smacks her and I was that
that come on that's when I was sober in
1873 you know yeah no 12 year olds has
ever seen that so yesterday my daughter
walks it walks and jumps on top of me
there's two priests to talk they're
talking about God and she was all that
[ __ ] yeah she went to st. Paul mmm so
she just prayers at dinner every night
she says present night she said taller
god bless
I could care less but they're talking
about God and then he's telling about
safe and she's like interested she's
like so faked and I'm like yeah but God
is always stronger than the same awesome
they walk into the room as Linda Blair
so my daughter's working with it she's
like looking at me and I'm like it's
gonna be fine my dad she starts gonna
wish she did when she went like this he
was it was really long yeah it was like
an alien sperm that was it was a oh yeah
my wife came in she goes you know you
really got to knock it off with that
[ __ ] don't you gotta see the world
the movie is x-rated isn't it no x-ray
no I thought it was x-ray oh no no no
from fright that's all I get up that's
the sequel to she did The Exorcist ooh
hey Blair yeah I think they correct
didn't they create the X rating for that
movie or something like that
it's ready to are on IMDB see what
happens when it was originally released
that's what we're thinking of yeah yeah
it was like Scarface cause it was so
terrifying Schrader and then they hate
he called in a hundred witnesses and
yeah yeah he's got a bunch of parts and
they wouldn't show the blade going into
his own right they were concerned
so the movie association made them go
like this and then show the blood hit
right what with the with the chainsaw
with the chainsaw because they actually
had the chainsaw going why did that love
this scene so they cut that out so the
guy who directed it did French
Connection than this yeah he's a fan and
then they were saying it barely escaped
the X rating but in cities like Boston
and Washington DC children under 17 were
not admitted it was treated like an X
rating yeah I want to see that
[ __ ] at the age of 10 at the
Union City cinema that it's a boat of it
may be [ __ ] up we want to see
everything at that so that came out in
the 70s I saw the Godfather there yeah
at the Union City cinema when they
showed the Denny's I [ __ ] with
bananas my face got all red I got hot
movie David I had this remember those
movies that you'd watch with your mom
and then there would be a nudity and it
was the what's the worst thing I saw a
Fish Called Wanda with my dad and when
they start having say his funnies like
this I'm just like comfortable
I remember accidentally like watching a
movie that didn't seem like it needed to
it was gonna have nudity in it and then
it would come on my mother be sitting
nice to me and I'm like oh this isn't
gonna be emotionally scarred I'm never
getting over this moment some of these
movies that came out for a few years and
they were called something they would
call the genre but the main to where it
was Kentucky Fried movie yeah screwball
movies really cool I think so yeah
Emma's my mother moon roof to the groove
to groove - that was a Chevy Chase
groove - group - but they showed Teddy's
group tube yeah the one that talked my
mind to get HBO for yeah Amazon women
was just like that
with Arsenio Hall when he gets killed by
everything in this apartment
oh yeah and falls up no and then they
extended that for as soon as he falls
out that extensive new scene yeah that's
which is that I want to check if I would
they're just being checked how do you
want to die it's like being chased by a
hunch about 10,000 like nude women or
topless women I need to see some guy
coming over the hill and the behind of
all these boobs bouncing up but now it's
good job right movie
that was the greatest girl like some
girl goes to watch some guy goes show me
you're nuts
and he just that's on you - that's not a
goofy the scene that's still nothing
like what was the scene that still [ __ ]
with me from Kentucky Fried movie we
will learn something we want something
there in court and the guy is like an
innovate the judge asked him like what
do you want to do and he takes a dildo
out he puts on his head he's like I am
from another planet and from the planet
dope though what I was like it was the
dumbest thing I just lost that the movie
theater and group - it was Chevy Chase
yeah playing the drums and some guys had
singing I'm looking over a four leave
client and he just smacks the guy in the
guy falls over then we just it was like
Saturday Night Live before all I've only
is he I think group to be even was
before Saturday like yes war was like
his first summer off yes he did SNL he
was already a sort of star into the
first year that I started I think yeah I
think maybe it was it was either after
his first year read I don't know we can
look this up a minute my favorite scene
from that was the daredevil from groove
- no oh Amazon know which one it was so
took you five movie the dead devil was a
white dude he puts on a helmet helmet oh
[ __ ] it overalls and he goes to
daredevil seeks out danger whatever and
he just starts walking he's in the hood
this is dice game hey just stands around
a metal and they all look up like what
the [ __ ] is this guy - it just goes I'm
just gonna do it he's just yells en
Mercer and he's running this is a
different thing it was like yeah that
was like anthology movies where was just
sketches and there were those three
movies all came out right after another
and then a day Kentucky Fried movie
which i think is the consistently the
funniest by far the sucker brothers who
made airplane next No
so as those guys the dead
Amazon women not by the Kentucky Fried
movie people know that's John Landis who
then directed no he direct American
Werewolf in London and what else did
land is I mean Twila is in the movie
that was good one
Animal House animal yeah he directed
animal I see yeah
Ramos wrote it and a pretty sure Landis
directed see if I'm an [ __ ] lately I
would Ted a commercial dish for John
Landis once and it was like oh you're
comedian look at my resume I'm like yeah
he's like I already performers at the
Commerce we should come in one night and
he goes I probably get mobbed and in my
head in like [ __ ] relax commercial
director he's gonna [ __ ] mob he also
[ __ ] directed thriller the music
video for oh wow I think I got trouble
he did the Twilight Zone
yeah he killed you get a lobby base but
guess what we were shooting a helicopter
shot I think he kept saying go lower got
Lauren some and they crashed her I'm
terrible happen he was a kiss of death
yeah Ramos wrote it with Douglas Kenney
and someone else and they don't know
that yeah from met I met Matt is
director isn't really
I met land this has had a pretty nice
conversation with him guess or what
spider-man - really he's one of the
surgeons oh that's right Doc Ock goes
crazy that's right so we shot he's one
of my biggest heroes except I love ya
Landis she's my favorite because he did
cool comedies and they did cool drama
stuff until he killed people with
helicopters who's the [ __ ] perfect
guy but you know he was very quick came
out to see he came on the set we were
doing the train set this is a great
story so I'm with it was there was a a
unit and a B unit to be unit was the
director for the Seabiscuit yeah this is
before Seabiscuit Gary Gary Ross so this
is like I think so he was the B director
on spider-man 2 but what happened was
you know it's like Raimi go and listen
you could direct this yeah let me do
this and I'll throw you the next one and
they gave him Seabiscuit yeah but he was
doing be and while he was shooting be he
was talking to me about shooting
Seabiscuit really it was either gonna be
next or he started nasty that's Gary
Ross it directed yeah
big so now we're all staying like he
wouldn't let me get on the train
yeah because I was too big yeah hey
coach Joey just go to hotel room you
bothered me and this guy are you really
like this guy us whatever they was with
you right thanks Garrett meant to
Samri Samri last another one my hero's a
great guy so the same suit everyone's
same suit everyday same white shirt dust
on the suit lint he looks at things
differently so now they're doing the hot
doc while we're doing the doc hawk scene
on the train yeah right across from us
and Sony they're doing the doc Hawk seen
in the operating room when he goes crazy
start depending doctors and [ __ ] yeah
but before lunch I see John Landis and
I'm looking at them and I know this
[ __ ] yeah man I got [ __ ] who
knows if I saw John - oh ma been there
for an hour i'm there for an hour and
i'm looking at it you know out of the
corner of my eye we're all eating yeah
and finally somebody said Joey butyl
gentlemen this way I'm like oh it was
very humble he wasn't very nice to meet
you how are you how long have you been
on the set I know [ __ ] 13 days and he
knows that's great you know tonight and
he had Blues on like on the hospital
blues and I go you directly no I didn't
say nothing he goes I got a scene as one
of the doctors
you're fired we broke it down he goes
you're fighting [ __ ] this is before God
gets to you he was very nice I remember
I didn't say much to him I didn't know
much like what to say I was a little bit
shy and then we broke and then I shot my
scene with the [ __ ] dude they shot it
from all angles and then you're like
you're wrapped this is the 14th day well
so for the last 10 days I would get
there early smoked dope in my nonno
trailer they gave us the condos in the
back of Sony
yeah nobody knows they got condos in the
back in the middle and they eat eat they
sleep eight per condone you have a couch
a big-screen TV which I didn't have in
those days they just had a TV remote
yeah
and I would smoke back there and like in
the hallway and then I would see him
because the Wardrobe was next door right
now he'd walk like a mr. Rambis whatever
Sam I talk to you
Sam finito yes joy what's the probably
Christian something you smoking dope
I'll get to the bottom of this every
morning I did this this serving lobster
tails on Fridays
yeah God you understand me this is this
is worth 203 - OH - yeah something like
that when did you say Gary Ross director
yeah Seabiscuit Seabiscuit I'm buddy
right the Raimi directed by the men's
200 - but Gary was the second unit in
your director okay so they go Joey add a
Mike if I met any of those guys they go
Joey get cut so before I met what's to
start from Boogie Nights that play [ __ ]
yeah Marky Mark no oh wow what's it say
Alfred Molina yeah you know I get there
I shake Raymond his hand thank you for
hiring now he doesn't seem too big just
let go back to your room every day I
would see him for five minutes and he
would crack a joke at me but the best
aisle from Bolinas there and he goes did
you guys rehearse yet they're gonna know
he goes by the way I'm so sorry
Alfred do you know Joe he goes no and
how from Molina puts his hand out and he
goes very nice to meet you and I go very
nice to meet you and our Sam Raimi look
said Moline and he goes I had a higher
room what do you want from me he did
good on the audition I was like what are
you talking about I'm just kidding the
both he is that's the type of guy he was
so it's the last day we rap yeah
I'm wrapped yeah so Sam goes over to see
what's at the thing I go to my locker
room I get the rest of my [ __ ] and as
I'm walking out I gotta thank the guy
yeah I gotta thank the guy so I walk in
I go mr. Raimey thank you for hiring me
you better piston he goes come and get
me and I gave how can I go up to now
you're the best to work director I
worked with he goes God because would
you just told me and Landis came over
shook man that was it oh man I the rash
- I went to a pitch meeting uh-huh I'm
sitting there and somebody teased me
they don't look who it is it's Sam Raimi
didn't say a word I kept my cool and
they came to get him yet as he was
getting up you know they coming at ya
[Music]
that lady came to get me and we all had
to walk up the stairs together and so he
looked at me he goes how have you been
and I go I didn't think I was in there
remember you gonna remember me just
please we still talk about cuz all his
friends are in those movies yeah yeah
and puts that whole Detroit crew in
there yeah yeah there's one guy that
still comes to the comedy store where
you gonna get on your hog and [ __ ] since
he told dad they've been doing yes he's
not the guy that the popular guy he's
had about 15 guys yeah he's got more
guys than him Sandler yeah then he puts
in his movies oh yeah it's that whole
crew from Michigan State yeah and the
whole [ __ ] crew so they're pretty
impressive yeah that's probably what the
[ __ ] oh that's a [ __ ] amazing did you
have like the guy agreed Evil Dead the
guy who wrote big the guy who who
created the American Werewolf in London
and directors around house all in one
set it's pretty you when you run up
against those people what do you do I
just try not to [ __ ] my pants but you
know the thing is everyone is sort of
just a normal human being I try to
remember not to be jaded about it you
know
now like every time I like drive on to a
lot where I'm working my offices on
paramon there was on Warner Brothers you
know I'd read to him buddy
anybody want to go to work today like
it's a [ __ ] accounting job and then
I've got an office on a lot and that's
what I wanted to do since I was a kid in
Iowa it's pretty [ __ ] great
it is cool too when you go there even
prawn dishes something it's not a level
of like working that but you go there
like [ __ ] traffic shove it and then
you see a like a an open-air tour bus go
by yeah these people are paying to just
look at where I'm going weird every time
and because there's trams going by all
all day about your rabbit it was cool I
would sometimes walk along with them
because I didn't know any of the trivia
[ __ ] I was like oh those the windows
from psycho I didn't know that that's
remember the first credit you saw like
we know the NLF was TV or movie for you
but oh yes it's still [ __ ] crazy to
me honestly like we just even when I was
seeing the rough cuts of the Netflix
series it's [ __ ] name when it says
directed by Jeff Tomczyk I'm so pretty
psyched about it yeah you know and
everyone like you know all my friends do
Grover
grew up in a [ __ ] town in Iowa just
sending me screenshots of Mike directing
credit on everything yeah it's tough to
get jaded but it's cool when you step
back and and like do put yourself in
that position of like a newbie where
you're like oh that actually that is
pretty cool yeah it's cool coming from
from from nowhere near here you know
yeah from Iowa Maryland [ __ ] God
knows where cuz you don't know where
your birth certificate is really fun
where's the RAM you know when you were
in New York you did a couple a little
like web series yeah yeah with comedians
yep and then you came out here the first
thing that you did comedy why's that
this is not happening
no no I am well I did those web series
I'd like to J and people yeah I was
first these these guys Pete and Brian
we're , do in New York and UCB Brian
SACA is on the show wreck now and Pete
left the business is now a therapist
which has got to be real top trouble for
his patients because he's so funny
you just deadly destroy this big hahaha
but but they dragged me in they
introduced me to like crawl and Polly
those guys and and and and and TJ Miller
and that's how I did like a you know a
pilot for MTV with TJ and Kroll and
those two dudes and like what happened
what the hell do you remember what what
when we met for this is not happening
what the [ __ ] else was i doing no you
were just sort of in that scene like the
UCB oh I made sure I made it that short
with TJ them at Sundance yeah you over
right before that yeah so I just come
out of Sundance and
Sam and Eric it was just like all these
young directors actors and writers yes
and the UCB or that world anyway I'll
call you see people just that but there
are people outside of Chicago didn't go
Island his badass and there's in watts
out of New York from God I can't
remember Diane I can't remember his grip
but there were a lot of people to kind
of my age that we're doing [ __ ]
now before you shot this is not happen
yeah which is stand-up but not really
yeah it's a former stand-up did you
watch what did you watch to prepare you
to shoot yeah but on the openings what
did you watch in terms of shoot and
stand-up itself well I you know I'd see
you know I've been to clubs I've been
watching people live a bunch and then
seem like what Comedy Central is putting
out as ours and I was the whole reason I
pitched on this not happening or what I
did was like that it didn't look like
anything that represented actually
seeing a comedy show you'd let go watch
Hannibal or whoever
except for mash up which door and TJ did
it was [ __ ] amazing there's a whole
different thing it was a whole different
thing but like most of those specials
look like a Michael Bolton concert from
1992 so Klaus they're all blue and blue
they look like they look like an energy
like something you know like a live show
for some Kenny G concert but they
they're supposed to be comedy and I was
like why why don't we try to make this
look like a club show and if you hadn't
really seen that and that's yeah give me
one to week
yeah so I never seen anything that
looked like that I don't know all right
was there anything that looked like this
is not happening out I don't know
no I guess like because the what was the
John Oliver show it was all said
something was there what was John Oliver
show [ __ ] I remember but I remember
doing I remember I couldn't get on it
right well now they're coming Central
one to showcase show that he did it was
really great shot at Webster Hall I
think right in New York where you shot
Jay special yeah
yeah but I can't wreck how can I my
memories going man I'm so old yeah what
was it China it was the showcase show on
Comedy Central but two or three years
yeah it was called like the comedian's
or this new standard
no no it was something else olive we
just called you Oliver know what Comedy
Central Presents or something new it was
something very general and I can't
remember but that was I mean that was
the best looking show other mashup was
like the best looking show that it's
it's still one of the best looking
comedy shows ever but I wanted to do
something that looked like a club show
look like old look looked like an old
Lenny Bruce show in a strip club that
was like smoky and gritty
I was already experimenting with out a
little bit you got special yeah special
was like yeah you guys have done the
show in in Montreal right Lima strip
club or and LA we are like secret Club
so I want to capture that feeling and
then I wanted you know when we start
talking about making the show theme
based which I think wasn't totally
initially how I would or no because
that's how you ran this live show a lot
shows that they were like should we do
that I'm like I like that part yeah I
really liked it to it cuz it it made it
seem like everything talked about was
the Matic which is really important to
me regardless of what I'm doing is like
I want a theme I wanted what we're
talking about where we're telling
stories about to matter in some human
way and I love that and I was like okay
how can we get people excited about that
idea like family or drugs or you know
what's the most bombastic crazy [ __ ]
thing we can blow up in the beginning of
this to feel like oh this is this is the
theme for the night so I just wanted to
do something as insane as possible you
know with our eating the cheeseburger
with a hole with his uncle exploding
behind him in a 10-foot fireball away
before that we did this the just the
moving around the Cheetahs hmm which was
was Shawn that was one crazy night yet I
remember that you know we had all we had
a lot of the comics there but but uh
who's the Oh Doug Benson could only be
there for like 15 minutes do you
remember this
no so I had to come up with something
where I could keep Ben Benson and
everyone there and shoot the damn hole
open in like 15 minutes
I have necessity out of necessity tell
me what with that so we came up with
that idea and I had a Steadicam operator
I called him up
we did it for cheap whoo
[ __ ] you're gonna keep does it [ __ ]
matter telescope great guy he's a great
guy now I'm gonna forget his name
because I'm an idiot but uh I remembers
the Instagram which is more [ __ ] up
steady mom that is what's ruined America
anyway we so we did this thing where we
just had everyone freeze and hold still
and and then we moved the camera really
quickly around everybody in slow-mo and
then we played it back it looked like
this very smooth slow shot just weaving
around frozen people and then I each
doing the craziest crazy like you know
like like Patton was like puking on on
somebody become safer on safer
no because Kinane is like pouring beers
on safer favorites knuckle Abrams is
punching somebody in that one of the
walsh brothers of the face segura
shooting a panda or no somebody else is
shooting in the pan and he's or the
elephant I was [ __ ] crazy anyway
there was we set it all up and shot it
and then Ari starts in the beginning and
then he ran around out of out of sight
of the lens yeah took off all of his
clothes strip naked and there's in pan
cuffed himself to the stripper pole in
front of all these extras that are just
holding still and had no idea that he
was gonna have their faces roofie away
from that they just had to try not to
laugh and inches away from are his giant
sagging ball sack they're just like
acting like they're cheering in frozen
in space
Comedy Central cut that part out we had
well we had it we had to blur it out but
it's very clear what's happening that's
my logo now those are getting so this is
not happening our self sensation there
aren't they were unheard of who they
were what the [ __ ] you guys were doing
and once I'd watch oh my god Jesus I
feel like the most pure that I've ever
been in my because I basically just sit
around and be like what's like what is
my twelve-year-old fantasy my Comedy
Central had to wake up to 40 and go what
the [ __ ] is going on
this is like nothing we have on this
this could not exist look at the
openings to this he's getting chased by
road warrior things I don't think they
even know what we're doing is we're on
our own
yeah we thought we did it on earth we
did it on the Internet at first so we
sort of snuck under the radar and then
it was a thing you know which was great
because it would cost [ __ ] zero zero
dollars I mean that first season I don't
think we shot the whole season for like
25 grand or something like this the do
tube season the whole first Youtube
season we never got a residual from
YouTube I'm just saying I know we
weren't gonna do well we signed
something really a sum to your face so
you just say you know a reason why I
really want you to come in mmm I [ __ ]
hate looking at myself
I just don't like this when you're on
the road I know I can't walk past a
mirror in the hotel room you look
completely different than your home bear
oh yeah cuz you're home ever favors you
because I hide the fat around your ass
and your knees Vegas when you're the
Vegas you like almost at Mother I got
bullet wounds I don't let that strip
where I spit on during the Laker game
hahaha so I'm gonna tell you something
right out like I I for years I shot
stuff if you look at mine DB Pro I shot
a bunch of [ __ ] yeah for years I pissed
everybody off because I wouldn't show
the premieres yeah you know screenings
at the rafters guilt and just ain't my
bag right right me I don't want to see
dailies I don't want to see nothing I
hurry I would be strictly honest with
you there's only two things I watch of
myself
that make me [ __ ] laugh my ass off
and that's the done story
Newsday I could watch the whole 14
minutes outside and get [ __ ] out of
the ring and say that that is one of the
best pieces of work that and when my
stepfather punched the cab driver what
one man I had so much fun shooting that
stuff that [ __ ] to me when I saw it on
tape first of all I couldn't believe I
was saying those type of stories that I
never told the story yeah anybody yeah
and it just you know it was
well I always said say the store I was I
had done that bit for about six months
and I went wrong where or not yeah it
only killed in New York it killed him
New York killed heavy in New York
because it's a tons of community yeah
but everyone else I'm gonna hire one
they were looking me like we don't even
know what a [ __ ] nun is I saw it kill
so yeah it was a theater maybe was in
New York Aviva trollee it is yeah yeah
that was like God and then we start
doing the show like dude you have to do
that story for me it was so good when I
didn't know that night I don't know what
year was that that we did that story I
can do what - 15 - 15 - 6 to 15 to 16
not 12 either a storyteller years those
yeah this is true as a writer to me was
one of the best right it was right over
season just three that was the TV season
yeah yeah didn't try to get mixed up
with one punch of the guy and I couldn't
speak Spanish and all that [ __ ]
maybe you did both those that night I
think man you're supposed to call her
see but half ways were you just switched
it couldn't say her real name ago she's
[ __ ] dead oh yeah we never arguments
could be that's crazy to me because
you've been on [ __ ] every even thing
I forget about that the the course of
time but we shot that first season for
digital on in 2012 2012 that's what it
was in almost seven years to the point
what's crazy yeah [ __ ]
I still remember going down to the first
time it was me you Marc Maron and
somebody else and I was gonna go down
there and tell a story about something
and Marc Maron mentioned Pink Floyd on
the spot I just saw him to tell my Pink
Floyd story with lubes and get an acid
and there's a joke that I came up with
that man on stage really but I revamped
it and use it today what was the joke
about I said I just was on stage in it I
said something about I in those days
there wasn't there really and New York I
never heard of a mushroom yeah oh yeah
there's no mushrooms yeah they were like
something
can you dreams about my people come back
I went to California in a magic mushroom
and he would be like a god like who it
was a kya hua scuttle a with all these
[ __ ] jungle ayahuasca and get the
same effect by going to the Bronx and by
a Chinese everyone I'll take you to the
same place and you need a void Passport
nobody knows your business you're gonna
go to Costa Rican [ __ ] drown
is that what the Costa Rica for the
honeymoon for their [ __ ] bats apart
is I'm saying a bats you know the
bachelor party is to me you get to your
friends you swam to secrecy maybe one
because you could always kill them three
you got a this true that could team up
on you have you got a hooky your [ __ ] I
mean you kill me you light them on fire
for five days take them to a hotel or
Vegas days before they just give them
dick put them in the closet when the may
come and make-believe like nothing's
happened when they come in hola que tal
clean you pull her out you start
snorting and you're [ __ ] that's a
bachelor bar in the seventies a bachelor
party somebody was sucking 18 dicks
there was anal it was [ __ ] blow there
was somebody I just went fishing that's
the party I was on probation
like what an Eightball and sat at home
my brother-in-law of my brother George
and we watched MTV all night snorting
coke my brother kept asking me why did
you just have an abortion
why jab the kid I'm like I'm marrying
your sister you when you started when
you still when you stopped the [ __ ]
that's my life that's why we'd like to
know what this is fire no but I don't
want gum on my [ __ ] carpet touching
it are you guys you're good point good
point I'm gonna get the come on cuz I
deal with don't do that cuz then I gotta
pay the security deposit you stepped on
gum like an idiot look on the floor so
the look on your phone when you walk
you'd think the [ __ ] gum was gonna
wants to make you pay the security
deposit here the [ __ ] drugs in the
ceiling get those two batteries you see
those batteries right the funny
batteries there's batter right there you
see that that's that's Wolfman Jack
official acid what oh yeah nari I just
heard for the first time this acid yeah
really to keep bouncing on water as the
right they're not the wrong one you just
do to one of those that's it that's all
you need you don't want these no I do
wanna [ __ ] yeah with the battery so the
acid Lisa the battery and goes into the
acid to give it that full [ __ ]
but this this is Wolfman jackass yeah
bro you can charge your remote I'll do
this Joe just bag the cops pull yo on
the plane they don't know it's batteries
batteries I get 20 executives to look in
here and they won't find that bloody
yeah that's how I fought the genius I've
been flying with that for [ __ ] two
months
Bobby was just in case headed to last
week in West Palm Beach FL girl
downstairs in the lobby and I'm like I
got asked those dishes I'd love to do
this I went up and I guinea pig de and I
gave it to see how strong she wasn't 20
minutes later she they were at the show
they went to the show yeah and they were
like every time you talk about quaaludes
oh my god it turns us on do you still
get him I got no quaaludes I gotta hit
ass upstairs in my room and they dress
like I'd love to do a send give me five
minutes me go upstairs I went upstairs I
came back with two hits but the other
girl ate it and other people were there
from the show when I was talking to them
but I kept looking at that [ __ ] and
next thing when I started I watch of his
drinking like shots of tequila
what's the neck hair started rising this
[ __ ] like that did you get off on it yet
it's a it's mild what you're just taking
right now sure we took it before you go
before the podcast order oh you took
some sure it's not what are you talking
about some like a couple weeks ago for
the first time in yeah it wasn't that
crazy to me I thought I was expecting
him to just knock me it's not that
strong it depends on my mic so now I'm
ready whatever yeah it's not what it
used to be this liquid I had that this
guy gives it to me yeah I gave it to him
and
his buddy just said he loves the ass
that's really [ __ ] strong
I got mushrooms in there for you know I
got mushrooms okay I think these are um
I'm sure oh really
yeah there's a mushroom that's crinkled
up right there without an open idea
somebody on that thing right on the top
I'm leaving the day because I'm gonna
[ __ ] brush it up and break it up like
a bud one night and mainly smoking will
even know yeah there's my mushrooms
that's the [ __ ] penis of it yeah this
is that's a tremendous debt for sure yes
nice you recognize all right it's got
bounces of these it's been out there
like two weeks I'm gonna crush it up
going like you get more than mushrooms
or like I just gave you some four days
ago like the idea much more huh I don't
give if you were needed to get crazy how
much would you have like eight of those
like how much do you need to eat of
these yeah this is this is big look at
it look at this bag of [ __ ] mushrooms
I gave him this is a new one this that's
all really and she's she's like that's a
[ __ ] pillow bro oh my god that's yeah
there's my worst nightmare she's gonna
hear my glaze if I took it just like
potato chips five or six of these
holding fat ones so now was tagged was
that your first feature that was the
first feature yeah how'd you get tagged
pretty hard I I like sorry I had a guy
still thinking about it
I just got it through my agents on his
it wasn't that exciting but I read it I
was on a trip with my family that I
normally when I'm with all my college
buddies and his first year nobody could
come because it all had twins or we're
going through life [ __ ] or whatever one
one guy's brother just had a heart
attack so I was just up there with my
mom I read the script and you know it's
all about all hanging on to your
childhood friends and I was sitting
there in a boat with my mom instead of
my who's lovely but with instead of my
boys and I missed them and I realized it
was a real difficult thing to stay
connected them so I wanted to do it so I
came back and just went through layers
and layers of pitching until I finally
got to the president of new line he's
not a chairman of Warner Brothers
and that's how I got the job you know
just what budget of their film uh 26
what did you keep it out what did you
come with it well I came well I came in
under I think I'm over a million maybe a
million and a half under that's good and
but then we did additional photography
afterwards so probably even add a little
bit and yeah man it was fun it's crazy
though to feel like 26 millions is a
tight budget but it feels like no matter
how obviously yeah I've talked to guys
who've done like you know two hundred
million dollar movies and whatever the
scale of the movie is you end up you
never feel like you have enough
resources you know you're always is it
like do you think it's kind of like you
know what if you have an apartment
that's enough room and if you have a
giant house we'll just move [ __ ] into
that to fill that up so it's always like
as much room ready yeah I think so well
I think yeah then you start throwing
parties and having your hands and
uncle's move in with you you know it's
like you when you have that space well
it's also like making a studio film it's
sort of there's so much left to chance
that you have you're just covering the
bases the actors are expensive like
gathering everyone that comfortable
experience is not like when you make an
indie film and everyone's just like in
it for the game and well like you know
doesn't need a trailer you know we had
this massive base camp of traveling
around with us and like a huge crew of
people just supporting and feeding and
it was it you know we'd run out like a
giant church parking lot just put trail
the scale of it is crazy you know when
you're making it that big but a lot of
its just built to beat you you know to
be careful you know because you can't
you can't let the whole thing [ __ ] up
and derail you need you need like enough
people there that you're gonna get this
done so it's it's sort of like
cushioning the whole thing probably
weeks to jihad we shot 41 days with the
principal cast and then we had like
three days with maybe two days with them
with the child actors who played the the
actors as young kids and stuff like that
so that was right about eight weeks yeah
but eight weeks got them out and then
back into the hospital did you do the
thing where they flashed him back in the
hospital two little kids running around
now there that was that was all just
that was all just the
Dolf so yeah it was like playful at the
end they really were it was really much
because they're a terrific cast of
actors now beside calmly sensual and
this have you done any other TV it was
just
Comedy Central TBS up until now so just
cable sitcom no scripted all scripted
yeah so you think so far that like if
you had a pick your choice between
stand-up scripted in films well III love
it all it's all very different you know
I lied I want to do stand-up always
because there's something and this is a
big you know what why wouldn't this out
happening something I learned from RA
actually is like I was trying to like
shift stories honor if you remember this
I was like maybe we should help them out
make the story a little family-friendly
or whatever I didn't realize that like
part was like keeping it all very Street
and and alright made me honest about
like there's making it comfortable for
an artist to just be themselves you did
you did a great yeah one that's why I
was right I started to like you more
like this I was like this guy knows how
the key twice it re does do and I didn't
understand that was that was my first
stand-up thing when we first did that
for all my and I didn't understand that
and now that's what I love about it
because my job is to like make it look
good try to give it a feel but not you
know not prescribe myself to what the
comics doing try to stay in the
background and it's also fun cuz I just
go and kind of get to sit back and watch
somebody [ __ ] artists perform what are
the best thing in the world what I
learned from you and from doing that
that whole process to is that I don't
know if you have this on movies too
where it's like everyone has their sort
of talent and you trust people to just
like open up and be as great like go
into whatever they do and let them do
that as well as they can
yeah and for this first there's not
happening it was the stand-up it's like
do you prepare your story as best you
can
yeah you do your [ __ ] as best you can
yeah you know Calitri Jordan do the
lighting as best you can
yeah get everyone just like your great
[ __ ] go for it and then let's all
come together it's the best thing about
filming honestly is you have a lot of
people are incredibly talented in very
specific realms and also have ideas
about other stuff and sometimes really
helpful the same in movies for me like
doing stand-up I get to like relax and
let somebody perform and also you know
like making a movie is like a year's
worth of preparation to shoot for 40
days
it just is excruciating it's so like you
know I get to be a director and a nice
member when I gonna stand up and just
like sort of relax and let let somebody
else like lead the charge which is which
is nice so I always want to do that like
that's that to me is like more like I
want to create television shows I don't
really want to direct just episodes of
other people shows because I'm not I'm
not really creative in that process is
fun all these people are great usually
but like I'd like to like want to do a
show I'd like to create it and I'm gonna
and I'm gonna do things in between
movies I'd love to just go do stand-up
specials or series because it's just
it's just pure fun you know for me I
want it done - yeah that's also the
impact on my life honestly selfishly is
not so crazy I mean tag was great but I
also distress I lost almost 40 pounds of
the crew yeah six months - how are you
still fat they called me an incredible
disappearing man I would like waves it
really that stressful it's really
stressful
this just come from the studio or from
yourself or like for myself wanna do a
perfect job yeah it was my first movie
so I think was I was putting so much
pressure on myself - yeah this is my
childhood dream and this was it and so I
was trying to put everything that I've
ever dreamed of into one movie very
unhealthy in a general way to like put
her self-worth into into one piece of
work so but i yeah i would like wake up
in a pool of sweat every morning just
worried about this there's a million
things they're all like sort of in my
brain every day but you never know if
everyone gets there everyone's seeing if
I forgot something bla bla bla right
like wake up and remember oh the scene I
shot two days ago totally doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense I'm gonna fix it you
know just that
over and over and over again so it's so
fun but like I probably slept three
hours a night the most memorable thing
for me like I was never really a comic
like I did spots at the storm it's he
short told me I was a comic but nobody
else wanted to use me so I did tons a
[ __ ] movie it was really weird like I
could remember the good directors in two
hands and if you count all the [ __ ] I
did you go Joey just ten of them like I
work with [ __ ] like that I keep going
they're looking for something they got
no answers they're like whatever you did
in your audition just do that it's so
far it's so funny to maybe
so we're yeah it working hard a weird
thing in it because recently I've been
trying to like get a community together
directors the weird thing about
directing you never see each other you
never work together it's it's a great
job but it's also sort of lonely you're
sort of like doing what you learned from
like watching laserdisc special features
as a kid you know and taking classes or
whatever and trial and error you never
get to be in ever anyone else is set
really and also it's so competitive
especially coming up like everyone every
other director wants to kill you and you
want to kill them because there's only
so many jobs to get a certain point so
it's tough and and I've been like I've
been trying to like now reach out to
guys and like get together say I'm gonna
trade ideas great idea like how do we
how do we all be better at this you know
the last scene in Scarface yeah you know
about that you know what was well shot
it and they were having a director
convention so that rest gun fight
wouldn't [ __ ] you I'll take his all to
hell yeah Spielberg shot on camera know
when somebody else this is they all had
ideas they all showed up that you should
do this you should do that you know how
long it took well that's a funny thing
is like back then they were like they're
all these pictures of where it's like
where it's like Zemeckis and Spielberg
and De Palma it's Chris AZ
and Coppola and Ron Howard all together
all the time just like comb by each
other sets yeah just out to dinner I go
into each other sets supporting each
other and I've said I've been saying
to a couple friends of mine like we need
we need to do this they had they had no
so much power because they could support
each other and we're running around like
[ __ ] idiots by ourselves shooting
ourselves in the foot and making
ourselves crazy because you know you
isolate yourself you don't have a
community there's so much to have
somebody go oh yeah I've been through
that I to do this exactly even what's up
yeah even even you guys like talking
about like the process even like listen
to your story about Mitzi on your
podcast was like I related this to so
much because it is a straw you know took
take took ten years plus for me to get
here but when you never talked if you
guys talk to other comics but when you
never talk to another director for like
ten years you're just like just are
beating yourself the [ __ ] I'm doing
these things wrong you know I don't know
if this is right
I'm making the wrong choice in it it's
worth it you know all that kind of stuff
that you just do is him being anyway is
up mouth yeah
the taste I lost is why I asked you
about a f5 yeah that [ __ ]
another tabulation I did mmm-hmm all
they're gonna hate me for saying USC
guys except for Peter the guy did the
longest chard with mmm-hmm but I
directed I got directed by three other
USC film guys did he go and [ __ ]
status that comes with it is so high
that they forget what the [ __ ] they're
doing the other way they forget what the
[ __ ] they're doing yeah the best work
I've done is when I work with directors
who have started from the ground up
studied genre yeah now stuck to it I
don't matter the movie we got him Bob
wisely I don't know Bob Weitzman did I
don't know what the [ __ ] he did but we
did Dickie Roberts
mm-hmm-hmm no blockbuster sure but
heaven I have a comedy conversation and
I can understand he understood comedy
had just come off a head he had just
come along for something what's a weird
it's a weird thing I think about being
in that chair being in that position
that it gets your head it [ __ ] with
your head you know absolutely you
go you can eat in and you're insulated
you could do whatever [ __ ] you want I
realized this when I got the tag which
is not a crazy big movie or anything
it's it's sort of blue-collar comedy but
like I could literally just like you
know called hookers and done a bunch of
blow you know trailer not come out for
three hours and they would have
insulated me and protected me I'm not
that I'm not that guided to do that but
like you can easily fall into it like a
terrible power system where you're
you're supporting whatever narratives in
your head but the fun thing about it is
like you literally get to get to go make
everyone's day pretty fun every day you
get to blow stuff up you get to like
tell a lot of talented people and
different different specific towns art
department people perhaps people camera
people ladies you know the stunts the
grips the lighting guys like everyone's
got something that's so cool that they
do and if you just appreciate those
things it's just like a hugely positive
fun and it's cool just to be able to do
it because in this business at least you
needed okay from someone else just to do
it yeah like when you were talking when
you were just saying like when they told
you it's a wrap I'm entering that
feeling on anything I've ever done with
like that's a wrap on Ari it's almost
like ah [ __ ] yeah like you get tired
every day but when it's done it's like
god damn it like out of work again yeah
well it's also like it is a weird
magical experience even though it's
[ __ ] grueling that's the movie almost
killed me but like it was you know one
of the best periods of my life it was
also like a confrontation of like I
couldn't put all my life's happiness
into like the goal of making a movie
that was a dumb idea because it's just
another job it's a it's the best job
that I can think of but it's not gonna
make you happy yet thatif I had a
separate way to do that it was weird
when I got alright so the first thing I
book was Bronx County yeah down here for
a pilot yeah and I remember going on the
set and people weren't very nice to me
yeah
and at the time I was still
three-quarters of a criminal health
insecure yeah and I didn't really they
fired me like I say I had eight why
eight pages in the pilot yeah well we're
rehearsing by the day of the pilot I was
down to a grunt
I was so bad as an actor I didn't
understand that they did they plucked me
from the choir on a stage yeah the CBS
producer who thought I was displaying
right and I just didn't have the chops
and then I booked bass ketball and I
definitely didn't have the chops yeah I
was that early on was better yeah
basically ball was early uh and then I
booked the Taco Bell commercial netting
them the chops and then I went to acting
classes and then that booked the MBC
show three episodes with Harry
Belafonte's daughter John Astin son it
was like three people famous kids and
they were lawyers in the house and I had
episodes four five and six
uh-huh I was a recurring plumber this is
2000 2001 I'm a recurring farmer I'm
getting re I'm gettin uh I think there
was 1750 an episode 1700 Oh said no
please don't everybody talked about
getting 17,000 I never got 17 times I
got like 1715 episode yeah and I'll
never forget the first day they had to
tell me whether I feel on your mark
I'm like what's up mark like you guys
have no idea when I did BASEketball they
because I was on the set so long I'm
never gonna shoot me and know that
before they shot me I stayed up and did
like two eight balls I hit there's six
cheese and they're like you're the first
shoutout today and I'm like no and I
only had one line so I didn't think
they'd let me use it and they used me
they called me like how many tickets do
you want for the premiere I'm like I'm
not even in the movie like now we kept
you in so when I when I shot all those
things
I was totally in like when I went for
the sucker brothers yeah I was expecting
to learn like I was going on these sets
to learn and they were giving me nothing
and that the bass ketball was when I
went to uh was that nature hall was that
what was the second brother thing was
that bass ketball
it wasn't it wasn't trying Matt they
were just in it they didn't do it I was
it was Fame and then the Zucker brothers
directly yeah you're right because then
they did my
via Kentucky Fried Mafia they called the
sucker brothers oh really yeah
Kentucky's ekor brothers wrap all the
Linnaean mafia and they called the storm
that the guy didn't give me the note hmm
the Mafia would bill what's his name
that's in Jay Mohr yeah yeah I was in it
but it's a month the part of you is on
you cuz you only had a pager right I
mean the only way those days the store
you would call and you would get booze
you have a flip phone right now but it
was so wait I think you're saying you
got like what a failure failure Wade
Eiling worked with [ __ ] if I go on
this set I like the spot the director
yeah I'm gonna happy no one ever knew I
was the director they were I was that's
why I liked you yeah on the set that the
railroad we got a hat on with a feather
[Laughter]
if I ever do that I have your permission
to get that Seattle never forget that I
want me in the face I went on a roll of
booking commercials with those [ __ ]
fiber directly yeah I got a he go with
the assistant next door right next to
them at all times
yeah with a cappuccino in their hands
and [ __ ] and I shower I booked three
Nationals in three weeks
oh wow sorry got me with aqua Elbe arts
and Lawrence was just a Korean savage
Lawrence got you out for something every
week by Friday if you didn't go out
you'd still go out on me for a shoo-in
it was for a black role but good down
there you ain't doing none anyways you'd
be like others before you look can you
email me I don't have a pen and goes I
cannot email you on this one that could
be no paper trail but you need to go
down it goes they're not taking you but
you're going you were just getting the
insider info tomorrow's four years well
yeah Ari [ __ ] assassin of casting
director or agent assassin oh my god
when when of a hater the first left the
agency right here on Lankershim they're
a bunch of punks and he opened up his
own
place remember they were a bunch of
origin origin honks the lady was a fact
he was called she caught me the first
call right three years ago I'm back are
you gonna go with him or stay with us
and I'm like she wasn't scumbag that fat
[ __ ] Rock will left but I was a sudden
Bart at the time so aqua came to the
store Lawrence and he he was always a
gentleman
yeah always cool so one day I call are
we to go hurry I'm gonna find it's phony
absolute yeah drop tool engine on me
because I got the cash on me but I'm on
200 South labret remember this 200 the
Petco and this 200 South Lybrand yeah
that is a turn on the corner there's a
casting that's a yes right now cast
commercials out there oh my god I'm
gonna get the goose from Rory marshals
yeah I gotta get the deuce from Mario he
goes what am I giving you money for it
was such a sucker bet like what am i
doing
by this time he had already left me
thousands of dollar this one in the page
okay no I was happy I would just get in
total buys you're both on the road and
thought he knew I was good for it hold
on I gotta get a deuce with me and I get
there now he goes what am I giving you
200 the soup commercial you go right in
there and book and I go what he talking
about us as a mafia commercial go in
there and I'm like you know what and I
went in there book this bar it's the
next day and I go that's how you show up
with a Jew you show but remember like
this job you could have booked without
all their the casting director [ __ ] up
yeah I would've got a [ __ ] percentage
on that yeah
[Laughter]
it was hilarious because launch was like
ah you didn't want me with you with son
Bart Ehrman re now you want Megan
Lawrence I'm showing up in an envelope
like a real Jew because you got a point
and it was getting like I was doing
these cookies of prog hormones like
they're the worst
yeah Network promos for $306 yeah they
pay 305 so you see that idiot that jumps
up and down on TV and says watch the
week this week that guy's getting three
hundred and five dollars I thought a
problem well you'd make more than a
commercial I had no idea yeah NFL
problems anything for the NFL Network
okay so you gotta go away with a wrench
to get money out of them they're cheaper
than ESPN my people and Fox the Fox
Sports upon the one I didn't best a
sports show I was getting 150 is sketch
what holy [ __ ] that's it that's a credit
let's just play a lot for directors
right oh yeah yeah they did pay what you
know the thing is like on a national day
like I I mean they pay really well I
can't complain too like the actors still
making like ten times what the directors
the Act really well if it runs enough
and they get enough is not right right
right you know like brighto like I was
in this pepcid ad that I did anyway you
know it basically finance like two years
of his life I think yeah that's why we'd
that right now well then looked at the
degenerates that we did together yeah
what a happily I was happy that you were
directing it yeah but that what you shot
in the beginning is making people go
crazy it's such a cool [ __ ] opening
it's making people great I told Lisa and
she said how juicy its Jeff but it's
[ __ ] cool you really thought before
you and your brother came out yeah don't
tell me I showed her pretties pretty
early I have to put though you look like
a real badass man
[ __ ] Christina member we Casillas
made eight months pregnant I'm gonna
giant cocktail I can we walked in and
out of that building it was crazy she's
like oh joy my feet hurt oh yeah she was
a soldier because we went it went like
an hour and like went like an hour and a
half late it was already late at night
and that was like I got to get this one
shot them elegant days and falling down
for that casino it was like I hate ya
but like I can't believe it was like
five months ago how fast it go I know
man you know that I shot that I hope I
was doing press for tag you ain't got I
got to do the junket we take you all the
four seasons that put you in a hotel
room with a tag banner behind it and
they just rotate reporters through and I
didn't have to do as many as the actors
the actors that do like 70 fee like
three minutes they gonna clock you ask
you three minutes of questions take them
out someone else comes in ask you the
exact same [ __ ] questions over again
the whole day is that way
until you don't remember what time it is
or who's who's in front of you because
the same questions for like 70 people
you're like what is happens to you who
are you what's going on so I'd done that
and then I got done and flew to Vegas
went to the Brucker meeting to prep work
and then went on the next day and shut
that 13 hour day and I was out of my
mind I was just [ __ ] burning heaters
all day try to keep myself awake in that
casino and I was hos burnt and then I
came back we shot for those those three
days on stage and I flew back the next
day and went to the premiere for tag the
next day my all my family flew in
they're all just like where's the
where's the house where you know where
do we get dressed where we go oh my god
oh my god oh my god okay okay you knew
her you're gonna be fine don't worry
about it you know it was a hell of a
week man I can't I can't imagine that
that was all that same [ __ ] it looks
so [ __ ] cool looks great you know
it's fun when you like look Kristina's
like fine let's do it it's like when you
work with somebody who you trust for
whatever reason they earned your trust
or whatever you eventually get to the
point we're like okay
sure yeah I know I'm tired whatever you
got me yeah I was I saying Christina
didn't you know know me as well some of
the other people I shot her for a fur
that's not happening but not for a while
that was a couple years ago and then for
for a towel underground yeah but you
have a reputation a little bit she's
gonna tell them to go yeah no wait
remember that no no she just did this
not having I'm wrong no I was I was
thinking we knew each other before but
even you and you're [ __ ] making me
jump out of a plane or whatever or like
shoving dirt in my face
I kick re up every morning I was like
all right you know what we're doing he's
like no I trust you I'm sure you man
I'm gonna throw you out a car and then
you're gonna run five miles and then
we're gonna shoot bullets at you and and
then a helicopter is gonna pull you up
yeah I just random [ __ ] he was like okay
there were like two different times I'm
like hey man I pulled a hamstring so I
can keep doing this but if you pulled a
hamstring those wolves came running so
[ __ ] fast it's gonna [ __ ] at me I'm
like I give you a couple more runs man
but it's gonna be Limpy real wolves
chasing Ari was there anything about the
[ __ ] studio process that surprised you
that you weren't expecting it is just
it's weird you know everyone talks about
studio hacks and stuff like that and
executives being terrible the truth is
they're they're in this business for the
same reason any of the rest of us are
they're trying to make good movies but
like it is just it's so hard to get a
movie greenlit that they're you know
anyone executives got like a hundred
movies that they're trying to get made
and so like and there's only like 12
slots and Warner Brothers - yeah you
know so they just have no [ __ ] time
you know the imagine if like you were
trying to get a movie made and you had
to go to you know a hundred a week about
a hundred other movies it's just they're
just hedging their bets as like a
corporate process so hard is working
these people to death so it's not did
that they're smart and like the
president new line is one of the
funniest [ __ ] I've ever seen he was
just riff jokes like murder like that
like hang up the phone on him because he
would just I was like I can't I don't
even have enough screen time for this
many jokes man and but but there's still
little there's a little time their day
to focus and now in Rogers
like I realized like how hard it is to
get a director from like a team from my
level to like a studio directing level
it the learning curve is so steep the
politics are so hard the mayor it's it's
a marathon like the people that are
there aren't going anywhere
that's number one no they're not and not
going to do and i think that i think
that i think the MS numbers that they're
bad or stupid they're [ __ ] they're
smart they're good people
it's just a tough job it's as tough as
our job in a different way there's
they're dealing with politics and
[ __ ] that we don't even want to hear
about and they just moved out here to
make Spielberg movies anyone else did or
whatever you know so it's it's crazy and
like I didn't expect like the just the
have you guys seen that documentary
Icarus online but about the doping and
in like professional sports no okay it's
[ __ ] great
it's about like Lance Armstrong and all
that [ __ ] but there's a guy he was like
our amateur cyclists he rides the Tour
de France for the first time and he's
just [ __ ] like weep like weeping is
so hard and he does it again he's like
the funny thing about it is like when
you ride it the first time it feels like
those hills are just gonna go on forever
you have no idea when it's gonna end and
you do it a second time I mean it's just
it's brutal and painful and feels like
you're gonna die but at least you know
it's gonna be over all right and they're
doing a movie for the first time you
have no idea that that when that hill is
gonna crest and you're gonna start going
downhill again you don't know where that
straightaway is you know when the whole
thing is gonna finally be over and that
was the hardest part like I was just
like every day worrying about Monday to
worrying about day forty forest problems
and realize I had like pace myself I was
gonna [ __ ] flame out it at Mile for
you know that was the biggest the
craziest thing it's funny well I had
Peter Segal on the boat cam yeah he was
telling me like the longest shot almost
killed mm-hmm yeah because I never
anticipated all that football all that
camera come was flying so many directors
after I finished called me up that I had
talked to in years and really I'm gonna
take you out to dinner and they were
like now you get it Oh
now you now you understand how brutal
this processes and how how the whole
system just turns you up and spits you
out you know my guys are like sort of
cynical about that I'm like I'm like put
me back in I'm ready for round two me
yes have you started thinking about your
next movie yeah no I've got a I've I've
been running around I've got a few on
deck well it now it's a matter of like I
have like four now they're all really
fun and actually making tag really
clarified what I want to do like I
didn't think that I was like such a like
an optimist except going into making a
movie but I I do want to make things
with a positive message and that ending
was so nice yeah well it was like it's
like I stumbled into that like not
really knowing and and like but now in
retrospect I look at that movie and be
like I do really think that like it's
important that to like be silly in your
life to be happy like that's something
you should be being stupid something
everyone should be dogmatic about it's a
it's something human and that important
and having and being close to your
friends and I think particularly for got
particularly for guys for me like you
know grow up thinking with guys telling
you they like you know telling each
other that I love you or you know being
vulnerable talking about your feelings
with other guys is something that's
that's weak or like people call you
names or that you're gay or whatever
yeah exactly I mean that's I mean I
guess yeah exactly yeah yeah thanks I
was gonna say not much but yeah but it's
it's something that is that's important
to be happy and I like I think the like
now particularly afterwards that's
something that I want to like try to
push and what I'm doing is like you
don't have to like sit here and be angry
you can go say you know I've been
through hard times too like that's okay
you'll get through it a lot of movies do
it with like speech though it's like I'm
glad I have you guys a hole yeah but
tags just in that moment where they're
all playing yeah well the dumbest thing
ever and that's what equates them well
they actually do say I love you at the
end like to me the whole arc of the
movies guys avoiding saying I love you
to each other because they feel like
they're gonna feel like girls
sissies or whatever in the most insane
way their entire lives even though they
clearly love each other they finally say
it at the end of the movie and that's
that's what like takes them back to
childhood yeah it's crazy how I have
like 12 friends I tell my love changed
everything
eight of them tell me they love me back
I got four Jersey friends in the [ __ ]
die hard yeah well I will talk yeah
thinking about me like you know what
yeah the funny thing is like until I
made that movie I hadn't said that to my
sister like as an adult you know we had
we were like good buddies but we never
we were [ __ ] around and joked and then
I was like I need to just tell her that
I love her and now it's changed our
entire relationship your sister me and
my sister yeah
tomatoes much closer today I wrote down
it's one they tell somebody alone yeah
it's really important just somebody
haven't talked to him I did I call like
three people I haven't spoken to in two
weeks I know I was thinking about you I
love you I gotta go got something to do
even if they deny yeah no it's good to
do if it was good to do to wake up and
be positive
yeah you know people get pissed a little
oh you write the same thing every day
it's a beautiful day to be alive
and that's not what's coming out of your
mind while you're pissing that first
pitch that's coming out of your mind if
you're a comic when you hit the floor
you wake up and you feel a little [ __ ]
up you ever have that like you smoked a
little too much reefer night before
maybe it's not on the line maybe you
have too many cocktails and you're not
hungover and you're not blacked out just
but you wake up if you're a real comic
when you wake up and you're two feet hit
the ground sometimes I say thank you for
giving me another day sometimes I go oh
[ __ ] I got two spots at the store
tonight yeah and as I'm walking to the
bathroom I take my dick out and there's
I'm pissing
I'm already thinking about those two
spots at the store yeah the coffee
yeah like the two spots and coffee like
how fast can I get the coffee done to
really get my day going push it up like
I'm thankful as soon as I hit the floods
the first thing I'm my got spots tonight
the [ __ ] store yeah the best yes
I like the Laugh Factory and I I
remember going to prison and somebody's
saying to me would act so I haven't
talked to you a lot of guys are getting
Maddie you're too happy in the daytime
people don't like that here that's why
they walk around stone-faced yeah
because that's the what do you have to
be angry that's the more powerful thing
yeah yeah no I wake up in the morning
right first an apple that's a beautiful
gonna be alive [ __ ] get you Dixon get
you [ __ ] licks you know you're alive
there's a kind of wheel chair somewhere
that's out that it cannot leave you
that's the only takeaway one episode is
it a can I take a piss and while you
feel that stream is coming out of
yourself I have ancestor altar next to
me uh-huh
and it's pictures of the two kids had
died in the 8th grade that I hung around
with it's got a picture of my buddies in
high school that died yeah friend's
daughter that died and every day when I
wake up some mornings and I have to take
that 5 a.m. flight out of LAX yeah oh my
god I should just fire Justin okay like
why am I taking a 5 a.m. for Highway and
I look at that pictures of the ancestor
altar they go I bet all these
[ __ ] wish they would take up a
5 a.m. flight yeah exactly
you know exactly it's kind of crazy
something Joe let's the other day and we
were walking around smoking a cigar in
New York on a weekday and and uh we were
complaining about you know people
bitching about stand-up or whatever and
I was like but you know man sometimes
you gotta put off those blogs down and
just go for a second like we are two of
the relevant New York comics we're doing
stand-up in New York regularly you know
we're kind of running the scene we're
part of those groups the crew that's
like running the scene you know the 50
or 60 comics or so that's out here and
how many people that we grew up with
wouldn't kill now he'll be doing what
we're doing and how we're dare we
complain about like they didn't get my
bonus
I was so close in this place and they
didn't give it to me or whatever else
we're living the envy of 99% of the
[ __ ] country so it's like you gotta
be thankful once in a while sad
I went to the store I hate a bag of
dicks in the main room yeah buying my
lunch room and I went and I sat next to
Kate Quigley and somebody else and
somebody else
Dahmer era was up on stage I had a file
of DOM and I basically went up there do
is I got well up there I touch gloves
and threw a jab just to see my business
and yeah and I just thought of doing
kidney punches like Rocky like body
punches and I remember getting in the
car going down the thumbs making the
left
I'm calling Rogan and telling rogue and
I go
you haven't had VI how happy how lucky
we are to be doing comedy at the store
20 years later yeah right you know I
used to walk in there with all the guys
used to hate us yeah they used to hate
on us watch these young and changing sir
well I first got that wasn't the most
white guy there and then you had what
your foot down then some people like you
some people didn't right
the width is that and I say this with a
lot of shame our ways now I go down and
people call me mr. Diaz they walk you to
the door
security and I couldn't handle that
yeah like a year I'm like this I fear
it's not gonna go to the store no more
and now I just sit back and I handle it
I know you know what I did my time I
know my time with mitzi if they want to
call me mr. Diaz so be it
they want right so it's hard to it so be
it yeah this is what it is this is what
I've worked for yeah bro I want to thank
you let's take a break I'm on the
degenerates Netflix Thursday October
30th Mike yeah one last question
what's going on with so bucked oh but I
mean somebody told me they saw you
smoking a joint
nobody's New York City you look like
you've been a server for a month I gotta
say yeah look your house harp
Oh help me Oh worked on the rowing
machine got blisters all over [ __ ]
it's hard I hate it I was ready to do
one first doing good he's waddling at a
new level he's never waddled back I have
not seen him while running in the day
but I'm not that so
[ __ ] in fact I saw him via damn he
hold his breath and gets his heart right
oh I told he had a six-pack yeah because
I I was even at Danielle's and I yelled
burped [ __ ] I'm watching a soap
October he looked at me waved and kept
walking so something was suspicious and
then the next day he had the balls to
put on Twitter that a fan yelled at him
he didn't know who he was let me take
off if I yell at you you know who the
[ __ ] I am you know they're all these
little boys he that [ __ ] had a
12-pack under his arm in the dragon you
think he's drinking why wouldn't he stop
to say hello to me I bust and you're
right you're absolutely right 60 yards
from me
I go yo [ __ ] so buctober I figured
he'd come back talk to me kept walking
then the next day he put on Twitter a
fan it normally that would happen he
wouldn't post about it he posted I don't
try to like show that walking dog yeah
he's trying said that mother why we
stepped it up he's in the backyard
though I tried it for like two days and
[ __ ] over yeah I'm gonna extra hard to
make up for you guys I'm smoking like a
[ __ ] chick I was I was sober for like
five months beginning last year was the
best it felt so great yeah now I can't I
can't great once like yeah I forgot how
good this is to what you saw but from
something like once I was dirty days
sober from cocaine I know it was over we
were done with coke I was fifty eight
days off cigarettes and I started again
yeah you gotta chew the gum
you gotta chew the phone I saw that guy
I gotta try that guy you worked at each
other
what do you mean money work coming up Oh
stand up yeah I'm doing a live reading
of my script I wrote in college with
some other people okay
the remember 11 that at of the Bell
House it's gonna be so [ __ ] bad yeah
yeah he's so [ __ ] bad and then I got
my European tour and his that start
November 16th and Reykjavik and then
December 9th in Zurich I'm gonna be like
a big pimp you Bert Kreischer it was
only Europe I'll be so take us like a
doctor oh sure whenever I go to Scotland
or something like when's des come here
Mike first of all he's not gonna flight
this long
second of all neither the country
America won't let him out and Scott
won't let him in
asking that godfather no country don't
be in remember even Israel is that we're
gonna work the camera
my Lansky offered Israel a gift of like
5 million dollars and they were like you
can't come in to a [ __ ] show you just
too much even the Israelis don't watch
too much yeah
Ari Shaffir and always a plug on
official called double negative that was
produced by mr. Jeff Tomczyk yeah yeah
in Austin Texas it's out on Netflix now
what does that come out it's been a yeah
what are you sure though it's so good
you I don't know June or July or August
it's how about zone of them or something
like that when I'm done when it tells me
it's time to me Ari yeah yeah you
[ __ ] came while I want a thing
about you have Tom say my little brother
Ari Shaffir for stopping and helping out
the church or what's happening now is
brought to you and welcoming
it's orig let me tell you something
about the rich you know you know much
pointless stuff we carry in our wallets
receipts hotel room keys spent gift
cards the leather bifold that menus
resemble suitcases more than wallets the
ridge helps you carry less but always
what you need okay it's sleeker than a
wallet it's two metal plates bound
together by durable elastic elastic
bands the ridge looks nothing nothing
like a traditional wallet you get them
titanium carbon fiber and aluminum
options ensures there's no there's an
option for everybody what are you using
a leather wallet what do you like the
ridge is minimal a front pocket wallet
that's designed to let you ditch your
bulky wallet the original wall of the
slim rfid-blocking and lifetime
guaranteed
listen it's the last wallet you'll ever
buy it comes in titanium carbon fiber
and aluminum and a poly carbonate and
over a dozen different styles and colors
I'm really impressive I'm really
impressed but I brought wonderfully
tonight and I'm really impressive it
what I'm gonna do is this we're gonna
take care all right I'm gonna give you
10% off with free worldwide
listen to me worldwide shipping by going
to Ridge Wall
doctor you gotta see this to believe it
Ridge wallet calm slash Church again
that's Ridge wallet calm slash Church
use the code Church but what I want you
to do before you even do anything is go
to Ridge wallet calm go look at this
it's beautiful its sleek and it's the
future man you need your daughter's
picture your - I got credit cards your
wallet and maybe like a pass to the gym
that's all you need and once you've seen
the sleek design you're gonna lose it do
me a favor
again go to Ridge comm slash Church and
I'm gonna save you 10% off your order
and give you a free worldwide shipping
who takes care you're like a little Joey
nobody now again I don't know how many
times I got to tell you people I don't
know how many times I got to tell you
people that from now till December 31st
it's a player's paradise it's time to
make some money you want to make some
money my bookie is the way to go
you're looking at me going joy what are
you talking about my book my bookie has
been around forever they got great
online reviews and let me tell you
something they pay when you win and
that's the most important thing let's
say you're the kind of guy who likes to
bet a little bit but with a lot like
playing the numbers on the roulette you
can create a big parlay pick three teams
to win and if they hit all three you
could turn the yardstick 100 into 600
hours who takes care like uncle Joey
nobody there's so much to bet on right
now you got World Series ball you got a
hockey you got basketball college is
coming forget about it
my bookie is one one of the best bets
you'll be happy with all year I
recommend these guys because I trust
them like I said they've been in
business for years and then but nothing
but good uncle Joey and their mobile
site is easy-peasy to use stop being on
the sidelines it's time for you to get
in the game what I'm gonna do is this
what login to my bookie right now and
I'm gonna double your money
you're like Joey what are you talking
about you know the banking that lunch
I'm gonna double your money you put 100
and you get 200 use promo code Church CH
you are CH and you
get your first deposit matched a hundred
percent that's promo code Church CH you
are CH you play you win you get paid I
want to thank Ari for stopping in you
know I love him like my brother I want
to thank Jeff Thomson for stopping in I
want to thank the Flying Jew aka the
Christ killer but most importantly I
want to thank you guys do not forget
tomorrow night I will be in Cleveland
taking the sound out quick already
Saturday night sold out for Late Show I
want to see you [ __ ] I think I
got radio at 7 to the oldies station
then i'm gonna go buy slime and get a
pastrami sandwich i got some ten o'clock
[ __ ] TV show i don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing
but anyway hilarity is this weekend
tomorrow Friday and Saturday I got
George Perez opening up and that's all
you need to know I got the guest book
came out you saw me sucking the dick
don't bust my balls alright everybody
has to suck a black pickup one time in
their life number three don't forget
next Tuesday October 30th the release of
the degenerate milk jo Chris and Brad
Williams myself and two sensational
women and I wanna thank you for getting
that special on because of you guys I
want to thank you for your support and
the love that you guys give the church
have a great week have a great weekend
and I'll see you [ __ ] next
Tuesday tip top Magoo take that [ __ ]
melee playing the way